why does nobody know about the employee
retention credit I want you to get this
money you'd be crazy not to get this
instead of the car it's cash it's your
cash you paid this it pays up to twenty
six thousand dollars per employee that
was on the W1 or W2 or say W2 in 2000
and 2001. I'm urging every company in
America
to go figure this out for themselves
because that money has already been
thrown out of the helicopter waiting for
you to pick it up still good to be here
at the headquarters and
hang out with our team here what do
these guys doing
everybody in this room is helping teach
people about ERC
and uh always provide a beautiful
breakfast
and have people really learn about the
program all right Mr Wonderful here
you're at my YouTube channel we're
talking about something really important
today the employee retention credit
which most of you have never heard of I
certainly hadn't heard of it until very
recently and learned a lot about it
because this is probably the lowest cost
of capital for any small business
anywhere anytime if you have employees
between five and five hundred so I've
got the expert with me this is Josh Fox
he's the founder and CEO of bottom line
Concepts they're the largest processor
of these ERC credits this is a 170 page
program so it's not easy this isn't like
PPP we just call up your bank manager
and say give me a loan it doesn't work
there's not a loan it's an application
and Josh is going to tell us all about
it and how to get it and why I've become
yes the Ambassador and paid spokesperson
for this I love this program it's going
away very soon you got to learn all
about it let's talk employee retention
credit Josh Fox what is an ERC let's
just start there
so during the Trump Administration when
President Trump was enacted they came up
with the cares Act and the cares act
offered businesses three opportunities
you had the PPP loan you had the eidl
loan and you had the ERC tax refund and
almost everybody it makes a big
difference right there two of them are
loans and one's a refund exactly so the
ERC is a refund that's correct the cash
cash payroll tax refund okay go on sorry
I just have to make sure we got that
point I mean that's a big difference a
loan versus cash cash I like cash cash
that's what we're talking about okay and
the other loans are done so we're
sitting here in 2023 and the eidl is
over the PPP is over and the only one
left from the original cares Act is the
ERC and yes Kevin it is a beautiful hard
check in the mail where you get actual
cash from the IRS all right so let's
talk about how it works because it
sounds like to me if it's a if it's
employee retention credit that person
had to be an employee so I'm going to
make the Assumption this money is not
for the owner not for people on the cap
table not for shareholders it's for
employees right you had to have owned a
business but it's based on you having
W-2 employees in America not 10.99. so
as long as you had W-2 employees and you
paid federal payroll taxes that's why
you would be eligible so you have to be
on payroll in 2020 on the W-2 and you
have to be on payroll for the first six
months of 2021 on the W-2 correct so
there were six quarters the program was
open well walk us through the six
quarters so you had quarters two three
and four of 2020 and you had quarters
one two and three of 2021. okay so
that's how it's measured you have to be
on the W-2 during that period now let's
talk my favorite part cash how much can
you get back per employee that was on a
W-2 in those six quarters so the
calculation in 2020 to be exact Kevin is
50 of the employee's salary to a maximum
of five thousand dollars per employee
for the year of 2020
and in 2021 the numbers skyrocketed to
70 of the employee's salary to a maximum
of seven thousand per quarter how did
that happen
um they just changed the rules in 2021
versus because the chaos of the pandemic
so they wanted to even get more to keep
those employees on payroll 100 so if you
can get 5 000 per person Max in twenty
that was 50 in 2020 up to five thousand
Max and then what happens 21 000 Max in
2021. oh that's how you come up with
twenty six thousand twenty one thousand
to twenty twenty one plus five thousand
in twenty twenty that's twenty six
thousand dollars per employee that is
moment because that's a lot of money it
is now there's a caveat here the PPP
money would have to be reduced from the
twenty six thousand dollars so if you
took PPP loan one and PPP loan two you
would reduce the 26 000 so what we're
seeing on average Kevin is if you took
PPP money somewhere around ten thousand
dollars a person so let's say
hypothetically you owned a restaurant in
New York City where I'm from and you had
a hundred employees and you took PPP
money you would still get a million
dollar in the mail from the IRS so it's
huge obviously now the big question is
why does nobody know about this because
look when I first heard about this when
I first met Josh you know I've got lots
of investments in lots of companies I'm
a major advocate for entrepreneurship in
America and making many many investments
in entrepreneurs of which many suffered
through the pandemic when I first heard
about this I called BS I don't believe
it because I use the PPP we went through
the money center Banks to get it it was
very easy to do we had our CEOs call the
banks they got their loans and that were
well deserved and we used them wisely to
stay alive during the pandemic so when I
heard about this I said nah it can't be
true
but when I dug around I even called to
my politician friends Governor Senators
they didn't know about it I mean that's
how you know that's how misinformation
is that there's no information out there
then a bunch of people told me well you
can't get it because you took the PPP
also not true so let's ask Josh why does
nobody know about the employee retention
credit you know what's interesting
you're talking about the banks Kevin
because in the PPP loan process the
federal government made it very clear
that if you wanted a PPP loan you would
call Wells Fargo Citibank Bank of
America any of the big banks in our
country and they would process process
in Canada a pre-pp loan there's no loans
in Canada by the way it's just process
process that's all
um and here there was chaos because
remember in the original cares act you
could not do both programs so if you had
done PPP you could not do ERC in the
original program and when they changed
the law in 2021 the banks were not doing
ERC because it's not alone so you're
getting a tax refund so the government
never made it clear to anybody about how
to do this does your CFO know how to do
this not really he or she's never done
it before do the banks do it nope the
banks don't do it the payroll companies
yeah some of them are doing it as a
payroll company your accountant no your
accountant's never done this before
unless you have an account that went
into this business and bottom line my
firm Kevin has been in business since
2009 and we've been working with the
federal government and the state
government to recover money for Fortune
500 Fortune 1000 companies so a lot of
our big big corporate clients have
worked with bottom line to recover other
government programs we've done sales tax
and use tax on employment tax work
opportunity tax credits research and
development tax credits unclaimed
property property tax all of these other
government programs that have been
around for decades and decades that's
what we've been involved with some from
day one so when we first discovered in
2020 the ERC opportunity we were so well
positioned to take this on because this
is what we've been doing for 15 years so
you're a taxologist I would say that
okay now when I heard about this program
was real that's when I jumped into
action I said to myself well I could do
this myself I'm very fortunate I have
many many people you know that know me
and follow me millions of followers and
I should get the word out there but then
it hit me you can't just make one phone
call have this happen this is a very
complicated application process process
process depending on the side of the
board you're on and I say I'm not going
to do that myself who's got all this
infrastructure built up given there's
only 24 months left to this program I'm
not going to rebuild what Josh already
did in that's why we formed the
partnership so it's team O'Leary O'Leary
Ventures and all my people teamed up
with bottom Line's concept and said look
let's form a partnership and get the
word out there let's go to town and tell
every small business in America to apply
for this and if they do qualify let's
get them an expert to actually go
through the whole program and get their
application in front of the IRS as fast
as possible because it takes about four
to five months to actually get the check
but because Josh has spent millions of
dollars building up the infrastructure
way better for me to partner with him
than try and do it myself which is what
I decided not to do and now we have this
partnership this is a pure play on ERC
so let's talk about the services and how
this happens you go to wondertrust.com
you book an appointment with one of
Josh's experts they assess whether you
actually qualify for this then what
happens Josh there's two ways to qualify
and this is very vital to the
conversation Kevin in order to get your
ERC refund you had to have had one or
the other of the following things happen
you either need to have had a 20
reduction in your gross revenue when
compared from 21 back to 19 so you had
to have a revenue reduction
or and this is a big change also because
it used to be that you had to have a
revenue reduction to qualify that is no
longer the case I want to repeat that
that is no longer the case you do not
need a revenue reduction to qualify the
other way to qualify is to have a change
in your operations so you sent people
home or something
essentially yeah every industry is
different of course like if we used a
couple of examples like let's say you
owned a restaurant and your business
model went from dining inside to being
forced to dine outside that's a change
of operations or let's say you own that
same restaurant you were forced to go to
a delivery model that would be a change
of operations so pretty well everybody
had some kind of changed operation
during the pandemic which lasted a lot
longer and it was a lot more chaotic
than people thought which is why so many
businesses actually qualify for this
even if they took the PPP so let's go
through all the misconceptions because
when I talk to my companies the first
thing I always call the CEO say listen
you heard about this this is the lowest
cost of capital we can get for the
business I want you to apply for it and
then they come up with all these reasons
that they thought about it but didn't do
it walk me through the top 10
misconceptions of ERC well the biggest
one is understanding the W-2 versus 1099
right as long as you had W-2 employees
there's a good path for you to qualify
if you had 1099 you're definitely not
eligible I think that's number one okay
number two on the Hit Parade number two
is if you had foreign employees like
non-us employees you do not qualify but
if you had a foreign company and you had
W-2 U.S employees you can qualify those
employees that were W-2 and worked in
the USA so that's the foreign employee
rule okay number three on the head
parade if you got a PPP loan or you got
it second PPP loan there's still a very
very strong likelihood that you would
still qualify for ERC because the wages
that you used in your PPP forgiveness
application is only a certain period of
time and remember everybody this thing
was open for six quarters so even if you
had PPP forgiveness in a chunk of that
time there's still other time that you
can qualify for ERC okay so that's let's
talk about the confusion around how long
this takes to actually get the check
what is the real answer how long if I
applied today and I submitted my
application into the IRS when am I going
to get that check so it all depends on
how big of your refund I mean we've had
clients that have applied for 40 million
50 million dollars for one company those
companies definitely took longer the IRS
is taking longer it's being more
scrutinized but you know the average
application is really 250 000 or less
per quarter so as long as your
application was 250 000 per quarter or
less remember you could have applied for
six quarters so that would still be a
lot of money would be over a million
dollars those are happening much quicker
we've seen two to five months somewhere
in that range yeah that's not bad so I
mean you you really want to make sure
you put in an application with no
mistakes in it right for sure that's why
you need an expert to submit this thing
because the last thing you want to do is
wait two to five months to find out it
was done incorrectly so experts aren't
free what does it cost how do you pay
for the nice thing about us is we're
absolutely on contingency so we don't
charge our clients anything ever until
they actually get their money so we're
willing to work for months and months
and months for you the client and we
will not charge you until you get your
checks that's not the case for a lot of
unscrupulous players in this market
because when I actually started digging
into it and looked at people that could
process these applications
I came with inclusion there's a lot of
wealth for lack of a better word
schlocksters out there that are charging
money up front they want to hit your
credit card I called around and I
thought this is very inconsistent and
then when I asked how many employees
they had very often they wouldn't
disclose it so it sounded like a
mom-and-pop operation in their basement
or something we don't charge them
anything remember the key is that we are
finding people in this industry the last
couple of years that are startups that
are startups that have no employees no
tax experience and they're trying to
charge people up front because they have
no Capital to run their business you
know that's the problem so you need
scale to operate this now the reason
there's not a lot of competition coming
into the market anymore is this is going
to run out soon right yeah that's a very
good point so we're sitting here in
April of 2023 and in order to file for
the 2020 refund you have exactly one
year so you have until April of 2024.
but the Big Year remember Kevin the
numbers went up dramatically in 2021 you
have two years left to file until April
of 2025 for the 2021 refund so that's a
big deal this is about timing so if you
haven't heard of the program number one
you've got to dig in immediately because
this money's waiting there for you
number two is it's going to take five
months so you've got to really start to
focus on getting it done
let's talk about the actual nuts and
bolts Josh of what I as a business owner
have to do and how I interface with you
to get the information the W-2
information and what else how does it
work should I call you you tell me
you're going to qualify I can get you a
check for a half a million dollars what
happens next so the key everybody is a
document called the 941 the 941 is your
quarterly payroll filing that you by law
must submit to the IRS you do that every
quarter for your business what we are
allowed to do with this program Kevin is
to resubmit to reamend your 941 with a
document called the 941x so we are
resubmitting your 941x's we certify that
into the IRS and this is maybe the
coolest part of what we've created here
Kevin is we have Direct online access to
the TDS system of the IRS the transcript
delivery system so we have enough CPAs
here and enough taxes attorneys where
we've been approved to have our own
login to the irs's website so anytime we
want to check on the status of a
client's application and submission we
can do that in seconds no one has that
access that is super important to
understanding where your file is where
it is in the process when you're going
to get your money that is a huge
differentiator so in layman's terms
instead of calling the IRS 1-800
crickets you can check it immediately I
love that 1-800 crickets yeah you'll be
on hold for five hours if you ever get
anybody on the phone but this way you
can check by calling in the support desk
at bottom line Solutions and say where
is my application how far away am I
when's the check being issued I
understand you actually find it when the
check is issued right oh for sure so
what's nice also is we get a 2848 sign
by every client which is a limited power
of attorney and we get the same
communication that you get the client we
get to our office and we're going to
show you that a little bit later we have
thousands tens of thousands of those
letters that we've received and it tells
us exactly what date the checks are
being mailed to you which is the party
time the celebration time where you
actually get the money okay so that
means that you can take it from the
beginning from the first point of
contact right through the whole journey
and then after you the business owner
gets the check you pay your bill so
conceptually everybody if you have less
employees there's going to be a higher
percentage to process this thing and if
you have more employees there's going to
be a smaller percentage because the
money you get back is based on the
number of employees and the larger the
salaries that you paid these people so
we're willing to do it for a smaller
contingency fee if you have a larger
company it's about building the
infrastructure of experts that can
actually assess a do you qualify B how
to actually put the application together
and then see tracking it through the
system 100 so if there's anybody in your
audience Kevin who owes money to the IRS
today and there's probably a bunch of
you out there that owes back taxes back
income taxes back property taxes this
will be a Lifeline for your business
we've had many many many clients who got
a ton of money with the ERC program and
the government netted out the money that
they owed in back taxes and they got the
net money so they got this as a Lifeline
for their family and for their business
and now they're out of debt to the IRS
what a wonderful feeling the clients
that we've done this for
bring up a good point Josh I want to ask
you this let's say you're getting a
check for 500 and you owe the IRS 100
you'll actually receive a check for 400
that's correct is that 400 000 taxable
it probably is taxable so what's
happening here just to get a little
technical with the audience for a second
is you're getting money back that you
already took a deduction on in previous
taxes payroll
correct now I get it so you already took
the deduction now you're getting the
money back so they're taxing you for
sure well that seems fair it does seem
very fair now we have clients that had
large losses we have clients that had
depreciation from Real Estate and things
like that so they were able to either
reduce or eliminate the taxes on the ERC
depending on their specific situation
and so we've seen clients sorry that had
full taxes due and we've seen clients
that had no taxes due on ERC depending
on their past but for that you use your
regular accountant right for sure yeah
because that's the big problem this
whole deal what I discovered in doing my
own diligence on setting up this let's
call it massive education program is
that it is a very specific vertical
skill set to process an employee
retention credit it's not something my
accountant knew anything about or ever
it did now why is it the accounting firm
is more or less ignored this well
remember accounts are very very busy
doing typically regular income tax work
and audit work so how do they have the
time especially this time a year Kevin
as we're sitting here at the end of
April of 2023 accountants are very very
very busy with their regular practices
and just don't have the time to learn
this or do this so you've built the
infrastructure you've taken years to do
it you've got hundreds of people and
lots and lots of them on the end of
phones to help people to make this this
is not something you can just simply
automate just do everything online some
aspects you can but the first and most
important thing is to book that
appointment to find out if you qualify
and I've learned a lot about the
misconceptions my own companies included
over 50 of them so many misconceptions
about this program and the value of it
is so important because today as
everybody knows we've had the fastest
rise in interest rates in decades and so
it used to be very inexpensive money for
my companies like factoring you get a
receivable up to Walmart or Target we
used to be able to go to the market sell
the receivable for seven or eight
percent and get the cash we desperately
need to make the next set of inventory
today those same loans in factoring are
anywhere from 17 to 29 which is
basically all of our profit Chihuahua
yeah that's crazy and so this ERC
program is you know the zero cost of
capital you definitely want to get it so
I'm urging everybody and I'm working my
tail off probably 40 45 percent of my
day talking about this you're going to
see me everywhere all over the airwaves
on social media I want to be known as Mr
ERC slash wonderful when this is over
because I want every single business to
get this money because it's theirs is
there any limit on this Josh how much
money has been put aside for this the
latest number that I have seen is the
IRS so far has paid out 28 billion
dollars in ERC and it's not stopping so
it's not that there's a limit on the
money that the government is willing to
pay for small businesses it is a limit
of time so we're going to have the fomos
of the world right the fear of missing
out which people are starting to get a
hold of this thing they have friends and
family who got the money and they're now
saying I want the money right so we have
that going on but what's going to happen
here Kevin and we talk about this is
that in two years you're going to have
so many businesses in America that are
going to miss this thing because they're
not educated on it and if they miss it
they're going to go damn what a great
opportunity that I missed for my life
for my business for my family for my
co-workers and that's the feel-good
story here everybody is once the clients
have gotten the money and we've gotten
billions and billions of dollars already
for people is
are you able to actually do something
good with the money and so what we've
seen people do is we've seen people pay
down debt we've seen people
um go and get better office space we've
seen people open new locations we've
just seen so many wonderful stories of
once they got their ERC money how they
made their business better how they
increase the benefits to their employees
we've seen people do better health
insurance plans we've seen people match
their 401k plan for their employees is
all of the good things the feel-good
stories of what people have done with
the ERC money and it was the opposite
Kevin with PPP we saw people buying
Ferraris we see people being selfish
with ERC we see people doing good for
their communities and think about
inventory that's what I always sweat for
all my companies is where do we pay and
how do we get the next batch of product
to sell that capital is getting very
hard to find that's what really got me
going on ERC I thought to myself okay
if I have to wait 90 days to get paid
through retail distribution so many of
my companies are consumer goods and
services this is a huge amount of
capital with no cost to it to go into
running the business it makes total
sense to do the work so that's why I'm
spending so much time on it that's why
we're talking to you this morning and
today this is really important this is
absolutely 100 percent something you
have to pursue the most important is
simply find out if your company
qualifies yes or no that's very binary
yes or no and if the answer is yes we
take it from there we make this happen
for you and you get your check four to
five months later so what are you
waiting for what are you doing why
aren't you jumping all of this stop
listening to us right now and get online
to wondertrust.com on your cell phone on
your laptop whatever it is book that
appointment you know I feel like an
infomercial because I am but I want you
to get this money I want you to get this
money you'd be crazy crazy not to get
this this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity you know the way I look at
it
pretend in the middle of pandemic you
had to abandon your car on the street
right at the beginning of 2021 and the
police found the keys and they took them
back to the station they're calling you
saying come and get your car we want to
give it back to you instead of the car
it's cash it's your cash you paid this
on your W-2s it's your cash they want
you to come and get it we'll help you do
it I mean is there anything better than
this in terms of raising capital of your
company the answer is no because you
don't have to give up anything for it
you have to give up Equity it's not
alone you have to pay it back
that's my last appeal anything else you
want to say Josh yeah there's a word on
the irs's website that literally has
stuck in my head for the last couple of
years and the word is urge u r g e the
IRS has written the words on their
website irs.gov it says the IRS is
urging small businesses to take
advantage of this the IRS is a very
conservative group of people it's a
group of people that play obviously
incredibly between the lines but the
fact that on their website Kevin it says
that they are urging small businesses to
do this is an incredible shot of
confidence to all of you listening today
that you should do this and if you read
further that sentence after they use the
word urge what they're saying is that
we're now making it simpler and easier
and we're relaxing the qualifications
for you the small business owner who was
hurt during the pandemic to actually go
after this money at this point they did
press releases it's all over their
website and you can read it for yourself
on irs.gov they are urging you and
making it easier for qualifying to go
get the money you know it's remarkable
the tax code was written to support you
as a small business owner not to put you
out of business the idea is you need to
know the rules you can't play football
unless you know what the referee's rules
are same thing with the IRS I tell all
my companies they are not your enemy in
this case is the IRS is your friend they
want to give you back some of the money
you paid them
you got to do this this is probably the
most important program you'll ever see
for your business money back from the
IRS IRS that's right those letters
strike Terror in the hearts of small
business because they're worried about
being audited that's your chance to be
given a gift from them that's the way I
look at it they want you to take this to
support 70 of the American economy yes
we are 70 percent of the American
economy small business in America is the
essence of what makes this country great
so do not delay apply for this at least
find out if you qualify just do it
thanks John economics 101 Kevin Money In
Motion Money In Motion I mean that is
capitalism at its best and so if the IRS
gives out hundreds of billions of
dollars to the small business community
and you guys go out and spend that money
and people pay taxes on that money and
your employees pay income taxes on that
money they pay payroll taxes you pay
payroll taxes Money In Motion is what
creates a great economy and that's what
the IRS has been thinking with this is
to get more money moving throughout the
economy so please take advantage of it I
can't think of a better way to end it
thank you everybody for listening now
turn this off and go to wondertrust.com
and find out if you're eligible for this
thanks Josh yeah that was great thanks
for coming up take care everybody see
you again soon wondertrust.com